Here is my result.
I construct an omega matrix of size 3 x 3, and initially I set the top left corner to 1.
Then the vector xi, I set very first value to init. Everything else is 0.
Now come the important additions for the first move and the second move.
Both times I do exactly what I told you before.
For the two involved variables, I add a +1 on the main diagonal and a -1 off-diagonal.
Same over here.
Then I subtract move and add it 1 row later, and the same with move2 and move2 over here.
Look very carefully. This is exactly what I told you about.
I'm going to draw this graphically.
I begin with a matrix like this. I then add this guy and then this guy.
As far as the vector is concerned, I start with this, add this guy, and finally this guy.
Then these two together are being combined down here
where I compute the inverse of omega multiplied with xi.
That gives me the vector of res, and res is being output using those "show" command
and returned from the procedure.